啊，
我一定要打破你们这种思维。
龙飞姐，
我的态度是，
哪怕我已经办酒席了，
哪怕我已经穿上婚纱，
穿上秀和服了，
哪怕我已经去到你们家了，
亲戚朋友都来了，
如果我当天发现，
比如说那些恶俗的闹婚，
那兄弟们啊，
我一上来那龌龊的嘴脸，
而我的老公不保护我，
不保护伴娘，
由着他的闹婚，
我当天都能翻脸。
姐妹们啊，
我希望你们都能有这样的魄力，
有这样的气势，
有这样的决绝。
我今年30岁嘛，
离异了一个女儿，
我现在是有一个男朋友，
他是99年的，
26岁，
我这段感情是否要继续，
因为他想今年年底带我跟他们父母还明年结婚，
我就有点徘徊了，
他是啥情况，
干什么工作的呀，
他是在国企上班，
一年年收入十万左右，
没有什么存款，
有一辆车，
家里是有两套房，
然后有一个门面，
但是他本人的话有几万块钱的网贷，
他说是明年可以还完，
他父母是老家是河北，
他父母是在开了一个门面，
然后是刷车的，
骑车也挺好的，
他爸爸妈妈有，
家里是有养了，
有100头，
养200只子，
独生子女，
我感觉这条件不对，
那你这头是啥条件的，
我这边的话95年30岁离异，
我有一个女儿，
有一。
住房，
我女儿的奶奶在带，
我女儿就需要我带，
但是女儿的抚养权是给到我这边，
我自己的话一年收入大概是20个左右，
工作比较稳定，
是一个小主管，
我存款大概有15个左右，
那男生他为什么欠账啊，
因为创业失败，
跟朋友一些吃喝玩乐，
然后月经运过，
这样子结婚有啥打算呀？
彩礼打算给多少啊？
彩礼的话他说给30万，
他给的挺高的啦，
顾虑的点是啥呢？
因为我已经有过一段失败的婚姻吗？
我不想说那么早的话再去步入一段婚姻，
觉得下一段婚姻你可能会跟之前的一样，
就的是没有太有安全感，
这样子我感觉是这样啊，
如果可以的话，
咱就是流水打出来确定看一下他有没有什么不良嗜好，
有没有这样，
有没有老去宽敞啊，
流水打出来看一眼，
踏实一点，
如果确定他没有那些不良嗜好，
我感觉这男方又是独子，
父母又很勤劳，
他又有一定的家底儿，
也给了一诚意，
说30万的彩礼可以考虑啊，
就是生不生孩子，
什么时候生孩子，
这事儿你自己可以定啊，
就是前段时间跟他好，
在我对感情方面就是有时候比知道没有安全感嘛，
然后跟他要分手的当天晚上，
他加了他的前女友的微信，
然后跟他前女友说他担。
是，
然后问他结婚吗？
被我发现他是用小号加的，
工作为信加的，
我觉得他跟我在一起，
我总感觉是以结婚为目的的去就是为了找个人去结婚生小孩儿，
所以我就有点才华，
这个重要的情况不早说呀，
婚前就金猿一马的，
婚前就搞这些小动作，
咱们本来就结过一趟婚，
生过一套孩子了，
知道婚姻是什么了，
婚姻里面最重要的是什么？
责任心，
人品，
信任度是这些东西，
那我觉得你还是再看看吧，
反正你也自己又能挣钱，
一年能挣20万，
你现在单身，
孩子又不用你带，
你现在这个状态多爽。
嗯，
是这样的，
但是也有一点感情吗？
有感情，
反正你自己第一保证自己身体健康，
第二做好避孕措施，
第三，
我们已经结过一趟婚，
离过一趟婚，
有一个小孩了，
所以我们要更理性的看待这个关系，
我觉得他就是有时候遇到事情有点婆婆妈妈，
优柔寡断，
但是北方人他是河北人还是湖南的，
就是南北差异也比较大，
如果我过去他那边，
我觉得他们北方的就是天气啊，
环境这些我都不太受得了。
姑娘哦，
你现在这个状态哦，
可千万别想着说，
哎呀，
我离开这里，
我放弃这个工作，
我再跟谁去组建家庭，
可千万别想这茬儿，
你现在一年能挣20万，
孩子又不用你带，
孩子抚养权又是归你的，
你现在又有一套房子，
你。
日子过得多爽啊，
我在哪儿挣钱，
哪就是我的家，
哪儿就是我的根，
就是我的大本营，
不要想着说跟谁去哪儿哪儿哪儿就是我们哪工作不一样，
但是是一个地方的，
可能考虑会定居在我们工作的地方，
不要那么着急啊，
这男的他自己还欠债呢，
再观察吧，
再看吧，
我感觉要结婚找对象的话，
别找了，
一上来又找一个欠债的吧，
对，
他是说明年就已经还完了，
你着什么急？
我目前为止对于他今年年底让我至于他老家看他父母这个事情也有一点纠结，
我觉得看无所谓啊，
当旅游了呀，
看无所谓的，
我看他，
他的一个红包呢，
是吧，
我反正没到那个领结婚证那一步的话，
一切都有反转嘛，
是不是？
对，
就是我这个人责任感太重了，
如果我答应跟他去见他父母或者怎么样，
我觉得这个事情就是在我心里，
可能就是说觉得可能就要跟他说，
千万别这么想，
问题姐妹啊，
我一定要打破你们这种思维。
龙飞姐，
我的态度是，
哪怕我已经办酒席了，
哪怕我已经穿上婚纱，
穿上秀和服了，
哪怕我已经去到你们家了，
亲戚朋友都来了，
如果我当天发现，
比如说那些恶俗的闹婚，
那兄弟们啊，
我一上来那龌龊的嘴脸，
而我的老公不保护我，
不保护伴娘，
由着他的闹婚，
我当天都能翻脸。
姐妹们啊，
我希望你们都能有这。
的魄力，
有这样的气势，
有这样的决绝，
那就这样，
拜拜，
就是女人啊，
活的道德感不要那么强，
不要觉得跟他见了一下父母了，
就好像不跟他结婚，
我对不起你，
那跟你见父母的又不止我一个是不是？
姐妹们，
你不要给自己树立一个乖乖女教养好又舍不得拒绝，
那舍不得拒绝，
记得点赞关注哦。